I mean women we're more depressed than
ever before we're on anti-depressants um
women over women over the age of 45 are
the least happy demographic a lot of
very the issue the isue and the issue
you have is women like Emily Rakowski
you know marriage again I've said this
before marriage isn't marriage anymore
the average marriage is seven years we
have things like no fault divorce leave
if you're unhappy so what does that mean
marriage isn't marriage anymore because
there have been so many marriages over
the course of history where people have
been very unhappy either the man or the
were very unhappy and they've been
forced basically to stay in a marriage
it could have been an abusive Mar